[Music]
there it is again
[Music]
reaching out to hurting people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i like that don't you
[Music]
[Music]
hello
there it is again so strong
[Music]
reaching out to hurting people
[Music]
what we're gonna do right here is go
[Music]
back
[Music]
way back
way back
[Music]
bum
[Music]
now bring that face over
[Music]
way back
[Music]
way back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
tomorrow go for a drive
[Music]
go for a drive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tomorrow go for a drive go for a drive
tomorrow go for a drive
[Applause]
[Music]
since i was a boy i've been head strong
always had me a sense of right and wrong
in a nutshell
[Music]
youtube for detroit years just busting
chops
and grinding gear time to listen up you
silly liberal perfect
you didn't make that shirt you didn't
build that four years ago when things
got
done i made me some calls and got me
some love
yes lotta with rider has gone daily
and since 2016 on election night
the mug club has survived
they tried to make me a hypocrisy
[Music]
and then abc decided for the copyrights
today they couldn't make us apologize
[Applause]
if
and in the end we decided that it was
not violative
of our policies for harassment
[Music]
[Applause]
can survive this guy's a fascist club
[Music]
noah and samantha
[Music]
[Applause]
you need to get out and we're going to
call them leave my restaurants
hold on
if you think this will soften us up then
youtube's got them a new laptop
[Applause]
[Music]
do you guys have papers
oh
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
that's worthy of a serious slurp yeah
because it's the victory stream today
uh that wasn't a joke i mean it was kind
of a joke
the whole youtube platform has been a
bit of a joke but use the hashtag
crowder remonetize everywhere on twitter
instagram let folks know
let them know this channel has been
remonetized uh i don't know my half
asian larry bill richmond what do you
think the over under is on
this lasting uh wait we're still yes in
24 hours
well i lose and apparently for some
reason the virgin vox got the scoop
before we did it
anyway uh we also have on the show today
brian cowan all right he's
obviously been in the news because he's
the most recent victim of the me too and
you know what we're gonna get some
straight answers from him i don't know
anything we're gonna do any of this
wishy-washy stuff quarter black garrett
is here how are you sir
i'm doing real good audio wait is here
it's not reflected in your paycheck the
re-monetization it's very paltry
i guarantee you this show won't be so
don't expect to be rolling in the
benjamins
uh and regis abandoned how are you sir
doing quite well
great morning to be here yeah it is a
great morning to be here
uh we're going to be talking about covid
and the junk science out there just
because i know so many people have been
removed
from youtube and from facebook uh and so
on our first remonetized stream i
thought
let's go through the things that have
gotten people removed
from facebook science
i think that's kind of important that we
should be talking about the science and
i have a question for you guys now that
not only the deaths have been
consistently going down but now that the
actual
rates of covet have been going down
which is remarkable given the increased
testing
uh good news do you think this is still
going to be the pivotal issue in the
election do you think that the left is
losing some leverage also let me know
what you think about us being
remonetized and uh if you think this is
a trend of things to come for everybody
else
so i don't spoiler alert
i've never seen anyone more in love with
themselves than uh reg the band
oh look he's looking at the monitor even
there that's like oprah oprah when she
interviews someone she's like um that's
that's interesting that's interesting
i'm actually looking at you because
i'm right here the mask is sort of it's
it's easy damn it red you're living life
through a screen life's happening around
you man
come on trash panda okay also subscribe
to crowder bits that channel has been
monetized for a while now
so you can write an article about that
lots of fun stuff over there
eat my butt which by the way i woke up
this morning after
reviewing that intro sure i woke up this
morning laughing oh yeah
my wife goes why and i said sure it's
still funny
eat my butt because he was profane right
swearing and then i'll
eat my butt yeah that's his sign off
yeah he ends every interaction
more of an open invitation he had a line
in the sand and he wasn't willing to
cross it you know
appreciate that principles i don't know
exactly what i don't think listen i
think we're reading too much into it it
was a crazy person on drugs who likes to
you know likes to get his butt munched
that's all i don't think we need to read
into it more than you know some
occam's razor there you go follow it too
but
that's what it is it's that simple
there's no illuminati butt munching
society
it's just bruce christ down at the white
house um
subscribe to crowder bits it is
monetized and do uh subscribe on android
on apple podcasts
and of course um given that
remonetization is a very very small
fraction of our revenue if it will be do
consider joining mod club at loudoun.com
club that's what allows me to have
my wonderful half charlie lawyer here on
retainer
to uh fight these causes so um let's go
to this really quickly
uh and then we'll hit the dnc teaser all
right because we have that live stream
coming up on thursday yeah we do
so first we are remonetized uh and this
has been going on and my half asian
lawyer bill russman can tell me when i
overstep my bounds
we've been talking with youtube for a
very long time about this
yes okay uh about 14 months a year and a
half
yes okay and to be clear the only the
only times we acquiesced or made change
you guys knew about for example removing
our
shirt that we had to off platform even
though it wasn't on youtube
and there were some initial videos that
we told you were made private behind the
mug club the paywall
yeah yeah but there were a lot more
conversations that had taken place
yep and there were a lot there were many
more requests
uh okay so
there have been a lot of conversations
and requests if you're worried about the
show
changing well we're going to be talking
about covet junk science and alex jones
but was remarkable what was remarkable
to me is we knew that we were going to
be remonetized we planned on announcing
this today
you can follow us on social media and
use the hashtag crowded remonetize we
said a major announcement on thursday
it's a major award
well there could be anything in a major
announcement um
and then we just see last night that the
verge
owned by vox got a scoop on it they got
the scoop
they got the scoop on it before they got
the jump on us on our own channel
you've been given the login info have
you no now were you surprised
i was surprised because again we this
was all discussed as to we shouldn't
talk about it before it
it actually happens right i mean there's
there's there's the question of
youtube on the record on it but also no
request for a comment but i think that
says more about the lack of journalistic
integrity that's true
than anything so yes you'd think you'd
want a comment from the channel that
you're discussing yeah you'd think
instead of simply uh using comments from
former
hires uh uh speech impedimented
brave latinxes so um now they're going
after
beautiful yes yes bill um we are going
they're going after they're saying now
that they're they're requesting youtube
examine our videos when trans
transgenders
attack right that was when transgender's
attack was the video which they say is
hate speech
as well as mashable said that uh we made
false allegations against black lives
matter
yeah they they were encouraging people
to go watch the latest change my mind
which we also encourage yeah and and i
think you which we didn't pay for that
plug by the way we'll be interested
yeah i mean we're getting very generous
of them to do that but i know what's
going to happen
everyone's going to go watch it and
they're going to be looking minute after
minute
this is the moment where i get to say ha
ha steven is a racist
and then at the end they're just gonna
subscribe
well hopefully then maybe we might need
it now when they say that we made false
allegations against black lives matter
which
we would request mashable or the youtube
spokesperson i'm not quite one way
who said this or mashable but i would
request you um find any
in that video what is is a libel or
slander which one is the written one
oral slander written is liable okay all
right is there some crossover is that
pretty
cut and dry uh no that's that's pretty
cut and dry i mean you might have that
audio video thing but uh
right which brings me to the next point
uh when transgenders
attack battery and assault uh
because i don't know how we could have
titled it any differently
if this is hate speech it wasn't just
when transgenders attack in general
because there's a higher crime rate
sexual assault rate which we've talked
about in other videos
it was about me personally being
attacked actually on camera twice
now i guess maybe because the second one
through the lunch box that he stole
that z stole from a hobo yeah uh
whipped it at me and missed that would
just be assault
in the state of texas assault would be
if you were a threat you were threatened
but the other one who came up and
directly grabbed the sign
and pushed me that would be battery
contact is where you get to battery
under texas okay so
okay i stand corrected the video should
read
when transgenders battery me just
doesn't roll off the toes
yeah that's not a snappy so i don't know
why you're mad i don't know how that's
the hate speech but you know what we'll
keep him coming all i need to do
all i need to do is go to a rally yeah
go to an lgbtq rally say hi
i'm stephen craig and before i finish my
phrase left hook
now it won't be a strong one
[Laughter]
i think i think what's what's going to
be what people are going to see is
they're going to read those they're
going to read the articles
and they're going to go look at the
videos and they're going to go wait this
is
this is the problem we have this yeah
this is this is scary okay so
we're mad that this that this this
attack was covered and
accurately described and then the other
one okay regardless either
of anyone's views on blm you're going to
see a conversation yeah that is the kind
of conversation that's happening all
over america but it's never getting any
attention sure and that's a conversation
you had about
blm yeah so can i define you to find one
false allegation that we made against
blm we took them
the links the sources which you can find
yourself we provide them for you
directly from the words of the founders
if not their own official charter and of
course the crimes are actually reflected
in multiple sources
see the fbi though corrupt can still
serve a purpose
um it's also important to note that the
journalists over there at vox
verge and the one on the same tomato
tomato tomato bad journalism
is julia alexander and this is the same
person who wrote the hit piece of
pewdiepie right the pewdiepie was
anti-semitic
digging and was the catalyst for the
first vox said popular so careful what
you wish for lgbtq aip
youtube community this is the same lady
correct yeah this is what
i guess this goes for journalism now you
know pewdiepie did some review of a
whole bunch of small creators he's
trying to do something nice right
biggest channel on youtube giving some
shout outs to some small guys so
of course they went through every single
video and dug through all the social
media of anyone he featured to find
something right yeah deep down in some
deep dive they said oh oh here's
something
slightly anti-semitic okay headline
pewdiepie is a nazi
right so i mean this is this is who
we're dealing with so
this is when i think nazis i do think
swedes it's to be expected
yeah it's it's like in the air if you
were to choose a democratic presidential
and vice presidential candidate who
between them
uh supported segregation uh lambasted
women
assaulted them and uh descended from
slave owners yeah and exactly
you just take those historical facts and
then here's the thing because we do have
people we have a lot more centrists on
the show than we realize
if people want to vote for a rapey jim
crow that's their prerogative
of course the country allows that yeah
the country allows it rapey jim crow and
listen we do have to give credit that
she that
kamal harris is the first pos candidate
and that's a big deal yeah
poc yeah yeah so uh let's move on here
to the covid which i want to talk
about now we have manny actually coming
out with some theories and brian cowell
on alex jones on monday that'll be a lot
of fun
let me one thing clarify i couldn't care
less if we are demonetized so
i know that the left was furious with
the vox adpocalypse right
you wanted us to be banned that didn't
happen you wanted to claim that we
violated policies that didn't happen
you wanted us to apologize and that did
happen for 26 minutes i believe if you
watch that
video you got to go back um and then
your only win was well at least we made
sure that louder with crowder can that
they will cease to make a living on
youtube
and that we made our living off of mug
club but you could still sort of cling
to well at least they're still not
actually making money on youtube so that
was the one win on the scoreboard for
you guys it was
you were one and six now you have to
wipe off the one
and put your put your mouth on the table
i'll show you how your friend just
smacks you for misbehaving
gotta hurt that's about what you got all
the victories are gone i understand i
understand what could be monetized about
we don't care our conversations with
youtube has always been we just want to
have a fair
fair shake on the platform yeah right i
know i'm not entitled to be uh monetized
i'm grateful that we are
that's great all of you will you know
get to observe me with my bonus
which is nice um which means we'll have
a couple other six packs
in the fridge great we immediately by
the way got emails your videos are not
suitable for advertisers i immediately
just want to play these videos are not
suitable not suitable not simple
please tell me what is suitable susan
not much we would say your hour-long
discussion with dennis prager and the
nature of humanity but uh you did say
that you smoked cigars so that's gone
too all right well that's fair
that's fair pewdiepie is the nazi um so
we do have that oh that's right thursday
so here's one thing let me say we were
going to be doing every single day next
week the dnc
convention yeah but then we realized
that it's like tammy ducksworth
like you know what who really cares was
it ducksworth and baldwin there's
several
there's several tammy's another baldwin
brother no good tammy's outside of bruce
she's you guys don't even know she's a
wonderful she's a lesbian conservative
and she's wonderful um i haven't spoken
with her i need to give tammy a call
someone here if i have an assistant
write that down call tammy bruce
uh we're only doing thursday and the
reason for that is because
the presidential candidate and the first
pos uh vice presidential candidate
will be uh speaking that night as well
as the whole biden family
which is interesting because i think
isn't hunter biden speaking on monday oh
that'd be fun yeah
yes he's it's like one of those youtube
videos how i make six hundred dollars a
day
um and then the next thing is from the
hello review you're like that's how
makes the money oh it's a review of like
this wonderful energy company if it was
600 a day no one would care the problem
is it's like six hundred dollars a
minute yeah
yeah that's true well tomato financial
corruption that's never investigated
so uh we will be doing a live stream on
thursday it's gonna be 80s night
drinking game
and uh here's a teaser
my name is joe biden i'm a democratic
candidate for the united states senate
can i get it on this
i was a democratic caucus there mendo
caucus
[Music]
no you haven't you're a lion dog face
pony soldier senators who built their
reputations
and career on the segregation you also
work with them
to oppose busing that's not
true if i were serving in the united
states senate
40 years ago when joe biden was serving
we would have been on opposite sides
i
and because i know we're under a
microscope right now i do have to
clarify fact check that
he wasn't opposed to busting job he was
opposed to buses
in general why do you need a car that
you know no one needs that much space
because it's municipal what are you
saying who happened
you're saying he also wasn't a
democratic caucus yeah he did that as
well
yeah it's very confusing there's no way
to fact check someone
who is functionally [ __ ] there's no
way to fact-check
the sentences it's just you know you try
and fight it's like then it ends up
being like tyler durden just you don't
know where i've been
we don't joe you claimed amy's diner it
doesn't exist
none of us can know where you've been
you lying crazy i don't even think he's
a liar
i don't think we can accuse him for
lying on anything it's a beautiful ploy
he could just lie all he wants
people go hey i think that's a lie he
goes what
who when did you happen they go what are
you saying ah
well with the koi pond and people go
okay you know what let's give them a
pass
so i hope you enjoy your potential joe
biden yeah
it's an interesting strategy gotten
let's see if it pays but most democrats
don't even think he'll make it through
the first
term which means that they think the
first pos
candidate who sided with jesse smallett
immediately demanding justice
is the one with the better judgment that
could be your president that's pretty
rough
think about that the person who didn't
have
the wisdom to simply discern hey maybe i
should wait on the jessie small
she went in the painting hard for jesse
he's the best person i know
this is a modern day lynching first off
for to be a modern day lynching
doesn't there have to be a lynching
doesn't that have to be one of the
prerequisites
and i think that tweet is still up yes
it's still up i stand by it you and
stelter
birds of a feather okay so let's go to
covet here since uh we can act like this
is going to have i don't know anything
wrong here bill you look cross
oh no i don't know counting doing the
litigation down all right well then just
just
count when you come in he's like county
he's like the count in sesame street
only he doesn't have the accent
that guy was an obsessive compulsive
count you don't need to count everything
that's true if you're having a bowl of
cereal you know like one she really okay
you can stop i have to finish
two cheerios you're like 14. you have to
flip the light switch on and off 18
times or his family will die
it's like count count he needs help and
cookie monster with his eating disorder
i don't know how you guys missed this
who gives a rat's ass that bert and
ernie experimented in college
these people yeah and you people are
entertained policy prevents you from
going after
count chocula or whoever you're talking
about that's that's racist
count shocking count chocula was a black
panther
who uh batoned people at the polls i'm
talking about the count from sesame
street
oh gotcha you're still not allowed to do
that okay well now i know
you're thinking of blacula yeah
now was that the dracula redux with with
the
dmx i didn't know about that there was a
no no no no that's
fine that's the cradle to the grave no
no there was a new dracula
in dracula 2000 ooh and there was some
kind of there was some rapper in it
i don't know who it was could have been
exhibit yeah so before he bit his neck
he was like
yeah exactly i'm gonna pimp your classic
novel
i think it
yeah do we know what it is they're
giving what was it dracula 2000
still recently all right he'll research
it but speaking of research let's move
on to this the kovid
uh right now if you tune into the media
you think that the kovid is uh is
getting worse
and worse and uh that everything our
president says about it is a lie this
has been the narrative
this is not true uh but let's hear it
first uh from the mouth of the first uh
ps5 vice president it didn't have to be
this way
six years ago in fact we had a different
health crisis
it was called ebola and we all remember
that pandemic
but you know what happened then barack
obama and joe biden did their job
only two people in the united states
died
two that is what's called leadership
but compare that to the moment we find
ourselves in now
when other countries are following the
science trump pushed
miracle cures he saw on fox news
while other countries were flattening
the curve he said the vice would just
poof go away quote like a miracle
so when other countries opened back up
for business
what did we do we had to shut down
again well that timeline is very
incorrect but if you didn't have a
miracle
you were put on the ticket yeah i don't
think joe biden wants to win this right
now
i think he's like one of those fighters
who's in the corner they're going get
back in there and he's waiting for he's
trying to give him every reason to not
send him back in like oh i think my arm
is tired like no
your arm's fine uh i think my leg
doesn't work you're like no no i think
i was like what do you have to do to
throw in the towel
increasingly more confused as he says
things yeah he's increasingly people
think it's an indication
of a cognitive client but i think an
equally sane explanation is he
is trying to get out of it yeah i think
that's i think it's true he's just gonna
i mean how i mean like how could he keep
happening and then i mean i
i mean he doesn't have anything left to
prove he should live out his life on his
back porch
with his wife and double-barrelled
shotgun so this is unrelated but we do
know what the movie was oh it was
dracula 3 000.
was it busta rhymes who was it so uh
dracula 2000 actually had vitamin c
dracula 3 000 3000 head coolio
oh wow dracula's paradise
so it was it was a dracula movie about
grandparents
i have no idea here's what's sad is i
know i saw it
i saw it and someone's going to accuse
me for being a racist because i confuse
exhibit
and coolio listen you tomato washed up
rapper okay the point is
it's pretty much all comparable as far
as junk science with kamala harris to
get back to the point
uh what are they oh wait hold on let me
see what's going on at cnn before i move
on to the junk science
i do watch that kid through a ball
teacher
teaching traveling to homes to help kids
learn look this is what we talked about
before
teachers want to teach some teachers
teach they
are willing to go school to school to
school but you're not hearing that
message all you're hearing about is the
like
you know a couple hundred that decided
they would like to get paid but not go
to school yeah and they drag out their
casket like it's a right undertaker
coffin match
yeah so if they're walking through with
caskets what is the obsession with
death with the left all time if we go
back we're gonna die
well listen there's a 99.97 percent
chance
you don't it's not perfect but i like
those odds
yeah i wouldn't say that those roles
should be i don't think the mascot for
99.97
life rate should be a casket sure right
yeah you know um you're saying there's a
chance yeah
yeah and i love that one of those recent
protests
they gathered at a school so all the
teachers get together and gather at a
school to protest
we can't gather schools right right it's
just like
just do what you're doing right now we
can't let children gather
what you don't understand is is the
natural coveted repellent
is acting like an [ __ ] that makes
the cell membranes
they're not they can't be permeated by
the covet impermeable
impermeable in penetration
my objectives are impetuous the thing is
impermeable my vocabulary is
impenetrable
um let's go back to the junk science
here
uh ebola is what she compared it to well
listen ebola's not at all com
it's not comparable i almost said
comparable you got me you got me on this
audio wait i am the worst uh you guys
can call me on my grammatical
inaccuracies we'll read your chat a
little later on and none of this is
behind the paywall i
like every other day of the week because
we give it to you free
uh because mug club and because we're
remonetized we want to celebrate with
you
so with for ebola what can people here
guess what the main difference would be
between ebola
and the co the covid the coved stars
it can only be exchanged through bodily
fluid
so it's like saying hey how did you get
the
whooping cough uh it's comparable to
aids
yeah no it's not at all it's like listen
no no there's a very specific way to
avoid this disease it could be
comfortable like just stop sticking your
penis in a light socket if you don't
stick your penis in a light socket
you will not get light socket penis
disorder that is the same thing
it is it keeps happening to me and i
don't know why
that's yeah i know that's what your wife
told me about the four hour erections
which you should consult your doctor
um unfortunately he's a man ebola also
you have to be showing symptoms so it's
it's it's
also you have to be showing symptoms and
then exchange bodily fluids so if you
get ebola
you really had to sort of be asking for
it also i'd like to mention someone
makes an appointment for that folks
under president trump zero ebola dust
zero
look at the arguments and you compare
them like interview to interview or even
within the same
interview or statement they'll go from
saying this is
the worst disease it can spread anywhere
and
everywhere we don't know anything about
it we have no idea what's going on
but you know who should have known the
guy who we said has been an idiot
you know that guy you know he's the one
that we think can't walk down a ramp
right you know so so so i just don't
understand why
he couldn't solve the problem but oh
wait we don't have a solution
either no but elect us yeah i know
exactly and like i don't know why the
guy in the leather helmet who keeps
going like this didn't know how to
separate conjoined twins we thought we
are stunned to find out you are not the
best amongst us
they believe that donald's a great point
that he's an idiot but he's some kind of
a mastermind or if he's oblivious i
don't
it doesn't make it none of this actually
computes and none of it really
can line up with the science this is the
issue right they do it with the green
new deal say well you're a science
denier if you don't support the green
new deal
i've done this on the channel you can go
search green new deal we read the entire
green new deal
because it's less than a pop-up book
okay tick tock went the clock
is more enthralling than the green new
deal green eggs and ham
is more flowery than the green new deal
and makes more
sense so at least it proposes some real
solutions
green eggs and ham by the way green it's
just penicillin i don't know why that's
so vexing
the great new deal is much like if you
give a mouse a cookie here
if you give ajosie a cookie she's gonna
take your whole government
right i mean that's just the way it goes
that's what she wants to do by the time
you get to page four the thing is
nobody gets to page four because pages
one through three sucks so bad
everybody's asleep right and if you give
a mouse to joe biden he sniffs it
and then it poses busting i mean one
real problem one thing with children and
now he's sniffing the mice
he's just well he's anything small
anything over which he can assert power
right it's a it's a power crack yeah he
just likes smells
okay uh here's something else that we
need to go through um
the united states actually comparing to
what kamal harris just said sorry we're
a little far removed from the clip at
this point
uh the us has the well how many per
capita let me
bring this up we have lower deaths per
capita in the uk and a lot of other
european countries okay
now here's one thing i want to be very
clear about and i've talked about this
repeatedly
uh yes if you look at the top states
that have the highest death rates where
covid has truly been
a pandemic they cut that they haven't
gotten under control they are
almost all i mean if you were to look at
it you were trying to look for some kind
of a correlation some kind of a
causation they're
all run by democrats right and all of
them had severe lockdowns that being
said
there are some exceptions and there are
some exceptions at the bottom of the
list where some states that had
lockdowns did okay but
most states that didn't do lockdowns
tended to do better and in the middle
it's kind of a mix and match so i
i want to be clear i'm not saying that
having no lockdown stops the spread
of covid okay but there is something
that is absolutely
undeniable and that is nursing home
deaths it's
not even close we're looking for these
graphs elsewhere and the problem is the
media never actually covers
these graphs the death rate graph has
continually been doing this
and now i am astounded to know that the
case graph is going down
how does that happen when you increase
testing yeah i went through the i went
through cvs pharmacy
to pick up a prescription for my wife
said hey you want to cut you want to
toss the coffee test in there
i said no i said are you sure we'll get
you the results free
what is this like a super size me copied
test yeah
give me the test by the way positive
um hey it's just like a
like a mosquito atomizer actually bring
it in i'd like to get this over with i
want to get it over with we'll just all
do the popsicle stick
test and blood brothers so if you look
at the democratic governors you have
cuomo you have whitmer from michigan
right
they um were forcing nursing homes to
take
covid patients now this is tough because
we don't have an
updated number on how many deaths
overall
our nursing home deaths but last time we
were able to access these numbers
according to the
new york times 41
of all coveted deaths are nursing home
deaths now i've read as high as 47
this is from the new york times and you
know they really don't want it to be 41
i wonder why we don't have updated
numbers we do not have those numbers and
you know that it's probably a lot higher
because it's cloaked in mystery right
now in new york governor cuomo is saying
that
they shouldn't have any kind of an
investigation he doesn't want there to
be an investigation he's rejected
the request the request for a count on
the uh and this is after he just fired
his chief of health right he went out
there continuously has attacked her over
the last four or five months when she's
been critical of his policies
and then went ahead and got the other
guy back that said
oh we should not do any kind of lockdown
at all period whatsoever
and you know it's crazy because now he's
completely on the defensive because of
this
of the facts of the senior characters
and what's more totalitarian think about
this you know that donald trump and
anthony fauci don't get along
they don't agree on almost anything but
people always complain that donald trump
is nothing but sycophants and he fires
everybody
he still has fauci out there throwing
pitches if you want to call it that
think of it for a second you get you are
fired immediately
if you disagree with cuomo and with
donald trump to where she gets some ball
busting at a press conference
fauci gepetto i don't like him but i'm
joking you're a good guy
say hi to your mom i'll see you tonight
that's about all you get he doesn't like
fouchy but he didn't fire the guy
he'd be well within his right to do
something and really all he does is go
out and say
no i disagree and uh here we go uh the
data is changing and
we need to reopen the country so it is
remarkable to me when we talk about
authoritarianism from donald trump and
you
look at places like new york you look at
places like governor
whitmer michigan my home state this is
the one that really upsets me
is governor whitmer she blocked a bill
just recently and i always try and see
the other maybe someone here can play
devil's advocate
so we played this video on the show
remember that that young man punching
the old man
in your face at the old folks at the
nursing home in michigan yeah
and people go why is that young [ __ ]
member
that's strange punching uh grandpa
why is he punching grandpapa they're
coming up with very nice then you
realize it's because he had covid so
it's like oh
oh okay so you could be you're a vile
you're a serial violent felon uh-huh
and you're under the age of 30 uh-huh uh
but you have coveted right this way yeah
i mean it's just beyond comprehension
when you think about it
you know it took me i read through
several times to make sure i had the
story straight that this is not anybody
who would normally be in a nursing home
right you're saying we've got someone
who's infected with a disease
that kills old people where should we
house them how about a nursing home
right this is just yeah and so if you
think about
you know kamala harris saying oh you
know hey ethel you still have that
kissing booth all right come on get on
up there
i mean we really have no idea how high
the toll is because
in new york it's only counted as a
nursing home death if they physically
die in the nursing home
right if you get hospitalized beforehand
as i assume probably most
would right then it's not counted as a
nursing home death so it may be
far higher whitmer hasn't been
transparent with it and she's literally
just
funneling uh you know i'm maybe she's
trying to kill off the uh
that's that's the conspiracy i've heard
like listen that would make a huge
difference in votes in michigan because
the seniors
it's a statement donald trump and
especially with 36
african-american approval it's going to
be tough it's going to be tough for
joe biden with kamala harris who's even
less popular i believe with black people
than joe biden if you can believe it
turns out being
being a braggart about owning slaves not
good bedfellows with uh
getting a little more of the
african-american vote so
yeah gretchen whitmer she's such a good
person she would never do anything she
would never do anything right yeah
i mean and i'm not saying that that's
the case but it defies reason and now
she voted to block a bill she actually
not voted she vetoed
a bill that would prevent coveted
patients from going to nursing desk
knowing what we know now so i can't
think of a more clear example of denying
science
i've listened i've relinquished this
territory i said hey you know what
maybe lockdowns helped maybe they didn't
we can look at sweden who seems to be
doing better than a lot of their
neighbors
worse than some other neighbors we look
at the top states they all had lockdowns
look at the bottom states most of them
didn't have lockdowns but you know what
we don't know it's a mixed bag
the one thing that is absolutely
undeniable is that the average covid
patient
death age is right up there at life
expectancy
in certain states like new york beyond
life expectancy we know that it is
severely more dangerous the mortality
rate is far
higher with old people and we know that
these policies that have put
sick coveted patients in nursing homes
have resulted in
innumerable innumerable enumer
innumerable it's impetuous
i am impenetrable innumerable deaths at
least up until this point
so then when constituents
representatives say hey we need to
change this in michigan given the
science right we're supposed to adapt
with science and i don't even really
think you need to be a climatologist to
understand that
sending in 22 year old criminals into
nursing homes with covet has been bad
for old people
they say no no this is good we're going
to continue doing it and gretchen
whitmer
vetoed that bill so still in michigan
today
sick covid patients right into nursing
homes
how do you claim that that's pro science
you were about to say well
what i find to be most interesting about
all of this is where's the criticism
for whitmer right where's the left
saying you know hey when she was kind of
on that short list for vp
you know you didn't hear the left going
well she wasn't possible
yeah well that's that's that's she is
not a poc that's correct
and so the the issues about this make it
clear that if this wasn't an election
year
how the left is handling this particular
problem would have been completely
different because at every moment at
every turn
if they can do anything and spend
anything to look bad about trump it
makes clear
they use it as message to say he's not
even qualified to run again
in november and yet all of the people
who were considered the candidates all
those people who are in power including
whitmer
and others in congress right doing bad
things as well
not making a difference in their
particular states and yet they're still
fine
it just doesn't make any sense blame
president trump for the pandemic and
ignore cuomo putting his pillar a pillow
over pop-pop's face if he jumps out the
window
you're gonna make me look bad so a
little dark but i don't apologize
this one's monetized hit the
notification bell by the way if you're
subscribed because subscriptions on
youtube don't mean a whole lot
uh and notifications will let you know
when we are live which is every morning
monday through thursday now good morning
mug club
next thursday we of course have the
special uh dnc live stream
in the evening uh here's another uh
point that we need to get to
the left of course has been claiming the
pandemic it's a pandemic pandemic
that's what i've heard uh is that it's
been getting worse and worse you
probably believe that too
well heating lies is a very effective
way to sell
look another another ass hat haircut
they had a meeting at cnn don't cut your
hair
every time he says something that's
untrue
but right now especially he must
the only thing worse than this
president's inaction
is his active about the reality
and this statement from the president of
the united states
is a lie
a pandemic which is disappearing is
going to disappear
reason cases are up because we're doing
one of the reasons
we're doing a lot of testing
the only thing that has disappeared is
his credibility
on this issue and the naked pictures
from your wife's yoga video i don't know
how much cnn paid to make that go away
yeah how do you get her off the internet
i don't know
for crying out loud he was just out and
the thing is also how does his wife
not check review before uploading an
instagram i guess it's just so
normal yeah is that my husband's flabby
non-squatting ass in the background
i'm pretty sure that's my husband's
flabby non-squatting ass he wouldn't
want people to see this all he does is
curls he doesn't want people to see his
flabby non-squatting ass there's some
publishers
you know i almost i think i think
there's some cracks in that relationship
probably at least one it was an accident
it was an
accident by the way sign these papers
don't read them don't read them don't
read them 50
so uh a recent survey by the way found
that
this has been effective from the left if
they talk about donald trump lying well
if you tune in to cnn it's
fear porn what are they doing right now
top republicans check it out embrace
quake canine aligned house gop candidate
i can never say canaan is that soros
against george soros even when they want
to call me
george soros is a conspiracy theory oh
and warren buffett was actually the name
of the actor who played munchkin number
five in wizard of oz
these aren't i like this guy politico in
june
i love how they they play they play the
video of her talking but they don't
let her talk no they don't let her talk
listen to what she has to say well i
think and there's more if you go to her
website which is unlisted on ours
full of conspiracy full of conspiracies
they believe that george soros
has a lot of money
[Laughter]
tin foil hat much unapproved soros is
like no no i don't have any money
oh yeah i do yeah well he doesn't have
as much as he would like you know what
ain't that life soros give me a call we
can talk about it
so um recent survey found that nine that
americans believe sir that nine percent
of the population have died from the
coronavirus so again if we're talking
about fear
and who's lying and whose lies are more
effectively reaching the american public
that would be over 30 million deaths to
keep in mind
yeah and even using their total tally
which is clearly inflated because of
nursing home deaths and the deaths that
are just deaths with coveted as opposed
to death by cobit
it's still under i don't know exactly is
160 something thousand right under 160
yeah is it under 160 i think it's under
170 depends on who you ask whether it's
stealth or cuomo on a bad hair day it's
somewhere between 155
and a million but it's certainly not 30
million
right americans out there believe that
30
million americans have died from covet
that's because they're tuning in to a
they're tuning into by the way people's
webcams who can't even be bothered to
rub a microfiber cloth over it
do you do with a ticker do we remember
back in april when they were saying the
death rate was going to be you know 170
000
and they were like look look at how many
people have died and uh
this is how many cases we have and they
were just taking the known cases and
comparing them to the
deaths and not acknowledging that wait a
minute maybe more people are infected
than we know about and the cases are
different and the death rate is lower
and they said what are you crazy
yeah and now that's exactly the banned
doctors right they're saying right they
literally banned
doctors for saying we have a higher
infection rate than we realize which
means a lower mortality so
now you hear trump going well the
numbers are going up because okay we're
doing more testing
and that's just the corollary of that
exact same point which is yes of course
you're going to have more confirmed
cases when you're doing more testing
what's not changing is there's no
there's no argument that he was saying
that the
testing is causing the cases no and
here's what's remarkable to me is now
even with more testing
cases are going down i thought cases
were going to be going up until
somewhere around
give or take november 4th that's what i
thought was going to happen but now
cases are going down despite increased
testing
and deaths have consistently been going
down we need to be clear about that the
number that really matters of course
is deaths particularly deaths per capita
here in the united states that has been
going down
consistently now cases i am surprised at
this that's why you never heard me make
the claim that cases would go down
it's so much winning even my fingers
hurt
yeah i think this is what is really
remarkable about that poll
is it's one of the instances where you
can see in a quantifiable way
the results of you know fake news and
and people just
getting people into a state of fear like
you can see okay this
is what is that 220 225 times the rate
yeah right right so so people have been
deceived that much
right you say tomato i say schools have
been shut down and they can't be
expected to do math
because our bravest could also be our
frontline heroes teachers would rather
carry caskets down lexington avenue
so uh i think i'm hearing that we have
calendar is that what it is so we're
working on it
okay we're working on it good so then uh
this is one thing i do want to leave you
with
um i i won't be surprised if we're not
remonetized uh but that's not really the
point is
when you were accused of being
anti-science when you were accused of
not listening to experts
you do have to ask yourself what have
the experts said
and what what have the people who've
been saying ignore everything else
ignore your lying eyes and ears and
trust the experts namely these governors
what have they been doing well they've
been sending sick patients
into nursing homes and then vetoing
bills that would prevent them from
sending even more sick patients into
nursing homes i don't want to be one of
those people who makes claims that
are unsubstantiated so anyone who goes
out there and says definitively that
lockdowns
hurt well we know definitively that
lockdowns hurt the economy absolutely
and we know definitively that there is
no rhyme or reason
yet to whether a state having a total
lockdown has
dealt with the coronavirus more
effectively we even know definitively
that sweden they decided to have a very
laissez-faire approach and their rates
have been going down
uh dramatically to the point that they
might completely be over the virus but
the jury is still out on a lot of these
however if we're going to talk about the
science and i do not know why more
conservatives aren't
focusing on this i want everyone when
you discuss this situation
this pandemic at your dinner table
whatever it is maybe
thanks won't be around thanksgiving
we'll be on to ebola number two some
novel form
of the uh of the the the bird and if you
have thanksgiving you're
you want grandmother to die yes don't do
thanksgiving you know
just have a you just have a can of
cranberry sauce alone with your hungry
man
swanson is not that bad the hungry man i
don't mind them i'm not going to do the
lean cuisine stophers
we should get them on as a sponsor yeah
lean cuisine not now
not after that you know i don't know but
lean cuisine they can find a sponsorship
over there at verge and vox with some
speech impedimented braves
um i'm wondering should we do do you
think we should have maybe brought
should we bring brian calanon first and
then have manny
yeah yeah okay so before we go to brian
cowan let's uh we have a quick break
what do we have we have a quick break
from our sponsors uh brian callan is
going to be on
right after this break real sponsors yes
and then after brian cowan we actually
have the truth according to manuel our
residential uh colombian conspiracy
theorist we'll be right back in one
minute with brian cowan
[Music]
hey hey guys what's up we got an idea
a bright idea laying on me yeah well
it's a commercial for black rifle coffee
coming yeah we're gonna show everybody
how good the coffee is
by beating your black ass yeah coffee is
so good
you're gonna forget we just beat your
ass i just i don't know
come on soak up the brands of that idea
we got going come on man you're gonna be
the hero
i'm gonna hold your arms back while i
keep punching you in the stomach
no i'm gonna punch you in the face no i
don't think any of this is necessary
it's not
it's not gonna work trust me well we can
we can run it by stephen but i don't
think he's going to be into it
okay yeah sure trust me there he is
right there let's go ask yeah go ask him
ah let grandma comey
yeah black rifle coffee
see i had to do like multiple takes
because i kept saying blackrifle.com
crowder because around the office we
just we just referred to as black rifle
we're on a
two name only basis we're that familiar
uh blackriflecoffee.com
crowder you get 20 off your first order
uh this is my favorite we just again we
refer to this as the medic blend here in
the office but it's actually i think
called the uh
the coffee saves or vintage roast we
have a uh
an espresso machine at the office that's
what we put in there it is
as good as any coffee we've put through
it and we've put through at least
probably 20 30 varietals so
yeah they're a veteran-owned company a
portion of their profits go to
uh support veteran causes that's all
great their coffee though
is better than the competition at a more
reasonable
price we're going to do some coffee
tutorials coming here in the future but
blackriflecoffee.com
crowder if you're going to drink coffee
support a company that has the
balls to support this show and they make
better
coffee it's a win-win
hey quarterback hey what's going on man
hey what's what's up guys
so we were thinking yeah we had a little
idea and it's a good one hear us out
we think you need a little more street
cred with the blacks
yeah yeah no offense but um so you're
familiar with
curtis 50s and jackson of course right
yeah right
so we were thinking 25
black
you love it because you're quarter black
no i get it uh
i get it it's perfect
nope
ah
what's up man nick
uh all right i think we're a little bit
off with the music because we don't even
do commercial breaks that often here
with the good morning
um but our next guest a friend of the
show friend of mine uh and uh i wanted
to have mine i think this is the first
show
that he's been appearing on and again
another grammatical error but i talked
myself into a corner
um mr brian callan are you there sir can
you hear me
i am here my friend um i appreciate i
thought that was a
baggy blazer turns out you're wearing a
rope yeah it's a morning show
okay well because i'm wearing a collared
shirt in the morning i thought you know
i i yeah i know but you thought wrong i
appreciate it hey listen i'm not the one
in the hot seat buddy
uh where's the best place where's the
bestest truth
it's the best places before this is try
i can no longer just wear a robe
whenever i want
it's true not right it's just it listen
if you see optics
uh where's the best place for people to
find you and support you right now
because i didn't want to plug the wrong
uh social well right now um it would be
briancallan.com
i am doing a well i had to reprise my
podcast
it is now the fighter in the rinks and
it can be found on patreon
so fighter in the ring setting patreon
um we had to go behind the paywall
and restructure everything we're in the
process of doing that releasing tomorrow
okay um because uh well
hold on before we go because brian i
want to give you the opportunity here
for people who
you've been the latest victim of of uh
allegations of sexual assault
uh people can say the me too that's gone
too far um let me just ask you point
blank
accusation of rape did you do it no i
did not
okay there we go not true all right well
listen and we spoke off here for people
who know this is how i uh this is how i
handled friendships i called brian i
said listen this doesn't read true to me
you tell me it's not true i'll go out
and i'll believe it and then if i find
out the prime line to me
then you know i'll bury him in his
collared shirt so
as well you should yes we'll just make
sure it's not a road
that's important though because no
matter what happens when you're in the
situation this is a crazy
you know 20 plus years ago whatever you
what happens is
everyone says to you the prevailing
wisdom across the board is
you gotta lay low you just have to be
quiet because
anything you say will keep it in the
news and and i i
i just i think a human being and i think
a country for that matter defines
themselves
on what they are willing to fight for
and and and the lines they're willing to
defend
yeah and and so for me i i'm not going
to do that and
because i didn't do this and i'm not
guilty of this and so
for me i thought to myself if i don't
stand up the number of people
that i know that have gone through
something similar who've reached out
or just people in general said please
please
be the person to stand up and at least
talk about this right because nobody
wants to talk about the fact
that we are losing due process
and i don't think anything anyone is
necessarily to blame but look
you have two factors one is social media
if someone
and it doesn't matter who they are it
could be from 30 years ago 20 years ago
10 years ago it could be whatever
it then if if somebody says something
about you and they said that you
said something that you did something
that's
all that it takes for your livelihood to
stop right because nobody wants to get
involved in that everybody kind of pulls
back immediately
and well i wouldn't even say i would
even correct you and say it's not that
there is no due process it's there's no
interest in due process and
i'll read this from the people article
where this this lady who came forward
and accused you people can read it where
she said she didn't submit to a rape kit
because she thought it was invasive she
also didn't tell her dad because she was
afraid her dad might hurt you
which to me this is just me my opinion i
go hmm doesn't like it sounds to me like
you'd want the dad to kick kick
kick a rapist sass you'd think so maybe
bury him in a bathroom but
but stephen the mistake is to get into
what someone's
mind how someone's mind works i think
this is a much bigger issue
yeah than just me i mean and that's very
important
i i think that the fact of the matter is
we live in a time
when when if someone says something
about you you can
you can be annihilated and you and
there's no redemption
and that is a fact that that is
happening and i think it's a function of
one whatever has happened in social
media it is this sort of
mob rule this sort of thing that people
jump on but also
you have publications you have credible
publications
that used to be really good newspapers
and stuff that are desperate
to get online subscribers paying online
subscribers right and these newspapers
are in
real trouble i mean desperate trouble
yeah and so what happens is there's
enormous pressure on journalists to
create click bait to create sensation
um and and so so if you get more clicks
if you get more retweets
that's that is the only way to survive
you know what's funny is you just said
something
that exactly donald trump would say only
at saturn more intelligent
you have newspapers that are in trouble
real
trouble bad bad trouble they need money
they don't have it folks it's just
it sounds better coming from you it's
the exact same thing
but but this is this is the problem
everybody
most people agree and most people don't
want to live in a world where you're
guilty until proven innocent you know
why because anybody can be next well
most people don't consider it until
they're that guy that's the problem
that's right and and listen the other
thing is the metoo movement is not a bad
movement this is a good movement
as far as giving people recourse to
abuse and and
and we've taken down some real monsters
but the problem is
if this process becomes arbitrary
random from anywhere any angle
and there's then lock them up throw away
the key and you can't earn a living
because when you talk about cancel
culture
actually what you're talking about and
people should know is that you cannot
earn a living
right you can't you can't you can't
support your children
right you can't support your your the
people that you love right
that's what's really going on and it
happens when you
posted a picture 10 years ago and it's
taken out of context
it happens when you've said somebody
said you said something
uh and it's very quiet because people
don't really even tell you they just
pull back
just everything dries up well that also
really bothers me is when you see some
folks not
coming out when they know something is
false to support allies or to support
friends because they're scared that
someone might go after them they're
terrified
listen i know what you're talking about
we just got remonetized today and then
verge vox mashable they all these
articles that
they're going to youtube saying that my
video when transgender's attack is hate
speech where i was literally
physically battered and assaulted by two
transgender individuals i guess they
would have preferred
when transgender's batter which just
sounds like a ben jerry's flavor at that
point
my issue here is that there's an
inaccuracy and there is a lack of
accountability now
they've kind of acknowledged that uh
brian and so i will say this i've never
seen
allegations or a story like this go away
so quickly as with yours and i think
that's because you came out strong and
forceful
uh also just because um there was no
substantiation right and the problem now
is the media realizes they don't have
the power there are people who can fact
check them so rather than try and go
back and forth
they they just throw spaghetti at a wall
and then they move on and so they've
moved on from this because there was
nothing really there and let me this is
one thing and i know you have your stuff
to say but i do know that there's a
history here okay and i've had my own
history
with this uh lovely lady um amy schumer
i know that you and her have kind of
what should i say uh got it under each
other's skin in her case more of it i
don't know her
well i know come on bro people can run a
search and see that you've said like
she's an okay comedian
she i don't think she's the best is that
what i said you said she was like good
but not quite to the level of and you
mentioned some like
like prior people like that which i
think is fair that's that's that's a
fact that's an objective fact
well she took that as well she took that
as as as an insult and she's been pissed
at you and then she put the stuff out
they're going
bye brian on instagram i'm going what's
going on so i don't think it's hard
for people to see the timeline and see
that there's also a personal grudge here
from someone who my opinion not yours
is uh awful in every which way
well look the the good news for me is
that
i've i've spent seven years building a
fan base with a with podcast
and and with my 20 years building a fan
base with my work
and i have been so overwhelmed not only
by the number of fans i think i had
something like 12 000 comments under my
my instagram and all of them were
incredibly supportive
i think people can see and all of my
friends and everybody i know over the
past 25 years the number of people that
reached out
people know they can feel whether or not
you're a good person they just
you're not going to be i don't think you
do something terrible and then
that's the only time you do anything
terrible and you have no track record of
it at all
right these are things that happen once
yeah they're a good person and people
know that
and your life is an example of that or
you're not well like brett kavanaugh was
a gang rapist
and then a guy who kept a diary it's
like brett kavanaugh mr
journals yeah yeah or spend his time his
whole life trying to get people to like
him because he's a comic and he gets up
and
you know does a song and dance that's
not an admirable quality i just love
when people like me because i like
people so right yeah it's a little bit
inconsistent
but again the larger issue forget me
forget me if i'm one of the bodies on
the side of the road there's so be
nobody wants to live in a world and we
don't know how to fix it
nobody wants to live in a world again
where you are where there is no due
process
where you are you can be executed by
uh an ambitious journalist no i wouldn't
say nobody has to come up with a story i
wouldn't say nobody i would say
most people when they sit down and think
about it unfortunately most people don't
sit down and think about it until
they are in that hot seat or a friend of
theirs is in the hot seat and there is a
huge swath of people
out there folks like the amy schumers
who tweeted this out with
joy uh or instagramed it out who do want
to see
people guilty until proven innocent not
most people but there are people
in the entertainment establishment and
the media establishment who do that
it's just not most americans um well
it's money you can you can get attention
and you can get money for it
there is an incentive structure
unfortunately there is an
incentive structure to do these things
and nobody knows how to fix it
and i think that's the biggest issue as
long as we have an incentive structure
uh to to where where you can make money
off an allegation right and i'm talking
about you know for for a publication
we we have a problem or not it's
happening all the time yeah
like at least i can at least i can get
up here and and
say my piece and continue to because
it's the only option i have
and uh oh come on it's not the only
option you have they have most
most people out there are supporting you
and i hope that you do make the rounds
and i obviously hope that we see you
there with your buddy joe
um this is uh it's really an incredible
time who would have thought that we
missed for the days of justice with o.j
because there was still that kind of
like did he did he not well have to wait
for the verdict and now it's just like
guilty and it's the opposite it's why
did is it because a cop used the n-word
no it's because the guy is white
well hold on stephen
sorry partially italian you have some
sicilian there's there's a a person of
color hanging
around your wood shed somewhere there
well who knows yeah southern italian 51
we all saw true romance all right uh
brian callan the best place for people
to find you and support you and i do
appreciate you it takes brass balls and
i would say this don't listen to all the
hollywood pr
people and agents telling you to be
quiet do what you're doing but where's
the best place for people to find you
and support you
uh i'll be on instagram i'll be i'll be
hitting the road as soon as i can
doing stand-up and i'll let people know
through my instagram uh
probably hopefully the t-fat k website
but definitely um
the fighter in the ranks uh on patreon
it's gonna be a great podcast
and uh we've already recorded uh one of
them so we're moving in that direction
i look forward to being here i look
forward to being your first
i look forward to being your marquee
guest brian callan thank you so much sir
i appreciate it be well you're a good
man stephen thank you for that robe
thank you and we are actually going to
go to a quick installment people enjoyed
it yesterday of the
the white privilege boys and then be
back with the truth according to manny
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
now okay timmy bobby and johnny if i've
told you once i've told you a thousand
times i need you to put your guns down
oh can't i just keep my gun on me
trained on you for just a little longer
please now boys you know i'm not
supposed to let you do that all right
just make sure it's unloaded
nope no okay now okay now at least
enough attack light you're blinding my
eyes
what am i going to do with you you
little rap scallions
ow oh those boys
what pickle will they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of
adventures of the white privilege boys
ah glad to be those boys i don't know
i'm excited i'm
not at all those scams you know there's
a part of me that would like to see a
couple of dimes from the re-monetization
at some point i'm not expecting to be
filling my coffers but you know some
beer money
that six pack is now down to a cult who
cares what i'm talking about but it
works every time
every time so uh next week by the way we
will have alex jones on monday
so just in case of that i want to make
it really clear we all said
we don't want people to think that just
because we're re-monetized that we're
changing so we said what would be the
biggest statement
someone who i don't even agree with most
of the time
just for you just for you verge alex
jones i hope to see that in the next
article along with uh pewdiepie's
allegiance to the nazi party i guess and
that's the socialist party could be a
socialist we don't know
bernie sanders right see tied in
together comedy
so uh let's go right now actually we
have someone in this studio
actually we have someone in this office
who we love smooth manny he's been a
jocko correspondent
uh wonderful man but he does come from
an actual socialist country and uh
yeah it's unfortunate sometimes i'm
pretty conservative but he goes pretty
far to the right
and some would say that uh it's
conspiratorial but i wanted to give him
a place to voice your opinions that are
not reflective of my own so
it's time for the truth according to
manny
oh and by the way before i should tell
you uh you can purchase your coffee at
blackriflecoffee.com and uh they have
the uh
coffee club if you do uh crowd or the
promo i forgot about the promo
yeah yeah if you do the promo code
com slash crowd or promo code crowd you
get 20 percent off your first order
uh i drink it every morning but i don't
know what's happened we missed a
shipment here i think one got skipped
and i told you i had to drink the local
cactus coffee this morning i tried
dunkin donuts because the only one open
at five
and to me if you're not open at 5 a.m
and you're a coffee shop you should be
shut down
i think you really should be firebombed
uh and dunkin donuts
is just like water yeah but at least
they don't hate america from whatever
maybe they do i don't know
who knows anymore so uh smooth manny uh
you're here to tell us uh
the truth that uh you think that
sometimes i don't necessarily dive in
deep enough
good morning stephen okay good morning
good morning i appreciate
you taking the time oh no uh so i was we
were walking by i think it was audio
away tonight yeah
and something came up someone was
discussing you were talking about
and forgive me not trigger warning but
warning if you have kids watching
apparently this is a real theory that'll
people in power have been engaging in in
in copulation with
with swine with pigs is something from
former prime minister cameron
you were saying this is true with i'm
just ignoring the facts
you're a very busy man you have a show i
only have so much time in the day yeah
exactly so it's hard for you to keep up
with all the news of the entire world
yeah but it is a known fact
well i should say allegedly okay an
alleged fact
that uh people in power do uh sexual
things
that uh might be uh immoral illegal
perhaps well immoral sure
sure yeah but that's that's a wide swath
that's not what you were talking about
yeah no
this one in particular involved a pig
okay but i i
will ex i immediately don't believe it
so i'm going to tell you a story
and we're going to dive deep into the
situation of the story
okay and why it's totally possible okay
well and i know is this
something that has to do with the black
mirror because that was the first
episode yeah and i don't know how
anyone's stuck with that show after the
first episode yeah i was like oh
sex with a pig this is the show okay
i've seen enough that's the pilot
yeah that's the pilot that's them
getting stranded on the island so tell
me what's your show about
i will here you go yeah okay so
so tell me about it so our story begins
with lord ashcroft
so he is a conservative he worked with
uh david cameron oh boy he has overlaps
okay and he
[Laughter]
yeah he brought them in uh don't even
know how they're going he wrote a book
alleging right that uh david cameron
did sexual things with a pig at a ritual
at a party okay at a price well that
sounds like heroes it doesn't sound
pretty sure then so the news breaks
and the news is like oh so our prime
minister
this is overlay number two
he stuck his genitals inside a
dead pig really yeah i don't know and
this was proven
so david cameron he's like he
he didn't even deny it he just went he
did the opposite
of what brian callan did just
disappeared but some people have done
that too with rape accusations it's a
strategy just to disappear so that
doesn't mean that he did it no
of course not it's it's all alleged then
a black mirror episode comes out
overlay number three and the first
episode is about a prime minister
who has to have sexual relations with a
pig in order
to save yeah that's why i say i know
this is a topic that but
people have been people have it was
spoken about in the office yeah and then
someone asked me online right
why i was ignoring this pig situation
and pointed me to black mirror it's like
a big thing
and i said let's have manny come on
because i don't have enough time
this is by requesting man it's not a
topic i'm fond of so black mirror
continue and i still don't believe you
you're far too busy to watch black
mirror season one
two and three and follow the news you
know right yeah okay
all right so so we we've set
the the scene that's what happened so
you've said nothing
overlay number four is david cameron so
this is about his age when all this was
a legend
and this was at a party called uh it's
called the pierce
gabeston society now here's here's
something funny about this
society if you bring that overlay back
up it's named after pierce gaveston
which was the alleged uh
male lover of the king and uh
you know saying alleged doesn't create
evidence right okay yeah yeah
i just want to make sure it works but i
just want to point out that fact that so
at this party
named after this if you bring up that
overlay again pierskaveston yeah well we
got that
um i don't know about you but
a secret society club named after the
male lover of the king is kind of gay
okay
no no it doesn't of course there's
nothing wrong with what they do and
there's a
place named after this fella so now when
we go into this place
basically what it is if you go to the
actual pierce games in society now it's
just a rich
party where the elite the young elite
go and um overlay number six they dress
like transgender prostitutes
okay okay some could say that i think
they would just say transvestites
transvestite because they're not they
don't
identify as another gender it's just a
weird knife well it's a lot of
cross-dressing and half-naked people
okay but you just show pictures of
victoria's secret models i don't see any
powerful
elites well these are these are just the
elite of oxford okay these are just the
ones that we have pictures of
right yeah i'm sorry i mean evidence
right okay
so what what do they do there so before
we
figure out what they do there how do you
know any of this manny oh you just read
the news
i know you're far too busy to read all
the news right yeah with the show
exactly oh well i have my sources yeah
the sources bill let's
look come on he's come in here i got the
guardian i got all the
weird ones that people don't believe
like the mirror and stuff right yeah the
new york times
complex yahoo news news that when you're
not supporting your theory you usually
hate but yeah
so if you go down to the next overlay
what i would like to present to you is
that in order for you to
play a power point in order for you
you need a clicker end up somewhere
where you might do something sexual with
a pig
right you need if you go back to the
romance one basically
degeneracy so you need somewhere where
you have access to drugs sex
and power and what that equals to is the
situation that
might have made david cameron do
something with a pig
okay so let's go to the director so just
david cameron no one else uh well
uh everybody else for sure okay
everybody everybody
there you go there's he just my
lifesaver get out of here
don't need to do in here manny can i ask
you this question yes sir do you believe
that
the that a large percentage of these
elites who wield
excessive amounts of power and have
limitless amount of money
are doing these things 100 yes and they
and they control the government right
is that they control the government but
they have power within the government
right yeah they're like
dave david cameron yes why are you still
alive then
he won't be after this program isn't
that yeah that's the whole thing we're
gonna be demonetized he'll be pushing up
daisy
i mean look i i that's just the question
i always have is
you know if if you go to someone and you
say look they have an excessive amount
of money and power
yeah and you believe that they can do
all these things and that they can do
all these amazing things and they can
cover it all up
then how is it that you know a 17 year
old anonymous person on
on 4chan is like is that something
something to do with controlled
opposition maybe
no i think it's something to do with the
fact that they love boasting about it
there's anything secretive about it okay
yeah and i will explain
so further down so now that we've
established the
the decadence of you know going back
so if we go to overlay number eight
first the first ingredient that you need
is a massive amount of drugs
right so this is an article from daily
mail about the pierce gabeson society
parties
and what the oh they all a lot of people
disagree with the pig stuff but they're
like listen this is just a giant
you know rave full of we're just like
all sorts of hard drugs
yeah yeah we're just having uh i mean
that's not so far fetched yeah
so there's also the drugs but because of
the drugs there is our second ingredient
which is
a lot of sex public sex and
in the highlighted part there this girl
is talking about um
some girl drinking some blood and a
party of overlookers wearing pig masks
well this sounds
like some girl talked about some girl
with something no she was there she went
there
she went did she have any evidence well
they take all your phones before you go
in
okay so one does yes but
if we keep going now so now we got the
sex of the drugs okay right lots of them
i don't know and these are the people
saying there's no pig stuff there's just
a lot of orgies out in public on hard
drugs
sure okay but what happens well you know
what you might say
well this this is just a coincidence
yeah but go to the next one one might
say that or one might say that there's a
lack of evidence
i'll just say amanda you've never been
to public school then but content
you went to school in a strip mall in
colombia that's not a joke
oh wait no it wasn't going where i was
here that was here i'm sorry our
schooling system isn't the best
columbia south carolina okay so we go to
the next overall
right so this is here in america you
know this is
the orgy dome in burning man where all
it is is
hard drugs and garrett could you read
that last
this is this is something i don't doubt
obviously at burning man and we had
these things in montreal that raves
where there's a lot of sex and that kind
of
that is a thing that's a thing yeah no
one's doubting that that's a thing and
no one's doubting that they're a weird
society
is connected no i'm saying it's normal
it's normal in certain yeah places where
people do this kind of stuff i mean it
goes
to the box saying it's normal i don't
think it's wrong and i'm not a depraved
bastard
it's definitely normal for people to
engage don't brag
listen let's let's set the bar a little
higher uh what you wanted a
quarter black hair to read the one yeah
you read the last overlay
um yeah so okay this is just something
that's
people are boasting about on the other
oh no i don't know that's a dozen
or something and i don't want to get ben
shapiro where these are
it's not like i don't want to say the
word vagina it's just that
that's pretty i mean that's the kind of
stuff that you don't want to read about
yeah well i think it was redacted by
someone in our edit bay
[Laughter]
so we we've established this is normal
right
i do know there was actually no i'm not
surprised because there was actually
andrew breitbart talked about this not
uh kevin jennings was the uh
kevin jennings was a jeopardy guy but
there was something ken jennings in
jeopardy
so maybe it was kevin jennings maybe uh
maybe uh uh uh
token allen can can bring us up there
was a guy think maybe it might have been
kevin jennings who
did actually teach and again warning for
people who are out there you can find
this on the old
breitbart state backgrounds big
hollywood who taught these kind who
spoke about these kinds of sex acts two
kids in school namely something that
involved
a closed fist uh and this was something
that was recorded you can listen to the
audio and i remember people were really
outraged and some people said well this
is just about advocating safe sex
practices saying
don't do that fist is safe yeah i don't
know well it's not necessarily safe it's
you know it depends it's i mean it's you
know
it's the black power symbol now so it
can mean a lot of things it's gonna be
joe lewis when you're entered detroit
okay it could or it could be
power it could be the communist
revolutionary workers fist
or it could be you know sometimes um and
that was a thing go google breitbart and
jen i think it was was it jennings kevin
jennings
kevin jennings yeah that was the story i
remember being shocked and i didn't
think was true no this isn't some secret
society
but i was surprised that this was being
taught to kids in school
and it was okay continuing let's wrap up
the slide deck
yeah you were correct that it's not a
secret to say that's just
normal that's sex education people do
that yeah yeah so what's missing in this
ingredient
because you know we got the parties we
got the burning man what's missing in
the pie
not it's a missing ingredient in the pie
not missing in the ingredient
it's only one ingredient but many
ingredients make up you know what
continue with your thing
so the fact that's missing and you might
just be like well these are just kids at
a party
it's uh power so if we go to our next
overlay
you will see that actually this happens
in silicon valley all the time
to the tech giants you know eat drugs
sex repeat they have
orgies that last days they do acid they
do nerd
this is just i do know about the
ayahuasca
you're what you read vanity fair
how else are you going to know about the
ayahuasca swine sex fests
you're conflicting your drugs here but
okay i apologize but again so
these are high people live they live in
palo alto mountain view they work in
silicon valley this isn't just people at
the desert
doing whatever people in the desert
might do right so what happens
what do you do people from silicon
valley go to burning man right oh yeah
of course they have their own private
places where they they don't have to go
to the orgy dome tent yeah
they got their own they are walking orgy
not with the peasants
yeah exactly we're at the orgy sky
lounge
high above yeah jack dorsey has his uh
orgy passport
he skips to the front of the line like
disney world he gets the punch card you
know
global entry six rg seven one's free
so when you have ton of drugs ton of sex
uh and power what you end up with is
a perfect recipe for blackmail and
kubrick talked about this in his last
film show
that wasn't his last film which it was
his last film he died
before he finished kind of a swan song
well it was
the ice white shot is basically
kubrick's suicide note just
begging to be taken out so and you know
steven you're way too busy to actually
go into the details yeah guys white
shirts
the reason
this reminds me uh i would like to tell
everybody to join my club
the only reason why we do any of this is
because of mud club well this has
nothing to do with michael
i want you to click yes i don't know
this was this was manny's own idea yeah
we have a
lower third yeah i mean he this is not
even me he brought it in
yeah okay well um just make sure the gif
includes this
all right manny thanks for doing this to
me well i will wrap this up
please in a nice little bow so now that
we go to our next overlay
we got the ingredients of blackmail
why do people do bizarre things they do
it because of blackmail
so in the nexium case which happened
here in america
that's not necessarily true one time i
dropped my pants and jumped into my pool
because betty was chasing a bullfrog and
i thought she was gonna drown that's
bizarre but she wasn't blackmailing yeah
but you weren't branding yourself
in a sex trafficking cult like in the
nexium case okay he got you there you
know
jeffrey epstein had a vast stroke of
photos in the safe
and it was just like his scrapbook yeah
you're kind of missing the blackmail i'm
going to say i can't dismiss all of this
entirely because
epstein was a real person and that's one
of those things where we all go
i don't know epstein think about it if
you bring up the last order the nexium
case
we have court documents that clearly
establish
guilty police on sex trafficking
violence psychological abuse
and the the ladies are hollywood stars
who branded themselves
as the images show and they did it
because of blackmail because
they they had things on them but i don't
know what does this have to do with pigs
what does this have to do with pigs i
love that you asked
so before we summarize he's
you know seville seville however you say
it you know he savile
seville yeah as a disney character no he
was a serial
rapist that pedophile okay attacked
at least 500 i understand okay that
happened in the uk that's what happened
cameron
is tiring david cameron is
they must be doing it together you're in
a pedophile
in your neighborhood hold on you know
you you went from england to nevada
i think that's where exactly they're
everywhere man yeah and
all it's all the same don't you get it
it's a pandemic money
blackmail so now we're finalized yeah in
our last
please overlay which someone claimed
at one of these gatherings where there
were
similar gathering pig heads on stakes
okay so if you include the sex the drugs
and the accessibility to a dead pig's
head it's not impossible to think that
david cameron
might have done allegedly he had sexual
things
[Music]
next time it seems a little all right
this is a little presumptuous
i don't know i feel like i'm convinced
already look it's
just an empty chair look at that look i
see an empty
chair by the fire uh there we go so now
this can move into a nice earnest close
let's get real serious what was that
last thing about the cube
the cube of saturn i don't know i don't
want to
i don't want to do i don't have to do it
no i don't even okay
cuba saturn huh well i guess now might
be my curiosity
um all right uh next week we have alex
jones on the show there's a lead in for
that alex jones in the show
we have another change my mind on
tuesday where you can see the whole saga
uh as it sort of transpired with antifa
we have the hodge twins in studio
and we have a giant live stream uh on
thursday
for the dnc here with you and it will be
80s night so drinking game
promo code phil all right ladies night
and uh reg the bandit thank you for
being here i know you won't be here next
week uh but the hodgepoints will such a
pleasure
thank you that'll be an upgrade from me
well no come on you've been a lot of fun
they're just you know blacker um
so well they are at 52 percent i think
they're twenty three months
together i did want to talk about and
this kind of relates to the youtube
re-monetization
and i want to make again very clear i
couldn't care less if we are
demonetized tomorrow again if it means
that we still get to reach you and
create the content we've always talked
about this
at a certain point making enough is
enough everyone here makes a living
we're really grateful that you've
supported us
that we did the mug club quarantine that
we're still able and we're able to do a
lot of good
like uh the david dorn shirts that are
available at lighthousecryptoshop.com so
we're really grateful
and uh at a certain point what you give
up isn't worth what you gain
in return so our priority has never been
being remonetized that's not why these
conversations have been taking place
it's just been well you know what when
you search steven crowder change my mind
abortion
i don't show up an eight-year-old pbs
video with 400 plates shows up right
these were our primary concerns
or like the the uh uh tulsi gabbard with
the election kind of stuff so these
things have been going on for a long
time and we've left a trail of
breadcrumbs for you um but you know i
hear a lot of sometimes you hear these
uh
conservatives out there and a lot of
people period when they find themselves
under fire they just go hog wild i don't
even want to use that word now after
that last year yeah
they go hog wild soon they say you know
what i'm gonna let it all hang out and i
will say this
um everyone here is is what you see is
what you get
but of course in dealing with these
things behind the scenes with youtube or
any of the big tech issues like we've
had with facebook before
we have had to be measured we have had
to pull ourselves back sometimes
and not out of concern for ourselves but
out of concern for the next guy coming
up the ranks because
when we have a target on our back and we
do now you see it coming from the verge
mashable i guarantee you by the time
you're watching this
if it's i don't know friday or saturday
there will be more mainstream press
articles claiming that
transgender attacks without having
watched the video is hate speech or that
our video claiming that black lives
matter should be classified as a
domestic terrorist organization is hate
speech with a big target on our back
and if they can make it stick then they
can make it stick on you guys and so as
much as i just like to go
sometimes we have to pull back uh
because
you are the folks that ultimately are a
legacy and you know this is something
that kind of
it sort of flies in the face of i had
someone uh say this recently hear it so
much i think it's even like a tim mcgraw
song as you know live like there's no
tomorrow how often you hear that right
live like there's no tomorrow
well there's a truth there's truth to
that right tomorrow is promised to no
man we know that
uh but it's horrible advice and it's
even more horribly interpreted people
see this often as
a meaning that there's nothing else
other than now than this moment but let
me tell you something
there is a whole lot more than now
there's a whole lot more than this
moment there is accountability there
is the eye of god on you whether you
believe it or not
you will have a legacy after you're gone
your actions will be felt there is a
tomorrow
even if not for you and like i said you
know again the bible tells us that
that tomorrow is promised to no man but
really if you read the context it's
stated to reflect the exact opposite
of how the sound bite is received now
i'm going to tie this back to how it
relates to youtube
see this idea of live like there's no
tomorrow it's taken to mean
well we're here a short time so make it
a good time have a good time now enjoy
yourself but again if tomorrow is
promised to no man
if there is no tomorrow for for you and
if there is a god
if there's no tomorrow but your actions
will have lasting effects
beyond your own life beyond your own
tomorrow
there's no tomorrow for you but there's
a tomorrow and a day after and a day
after and a day after and years after
and people will still remember your
actions and the example that you set
that should how would you act today
not there's no tomorrow so feel good
today but if you knew that what you did
now would affect everybody and leave a
lasting impact
on the world for potentially decades to
come and we all do
one degree or another how would you act
today would you just enjoy yourself
if you knew that let me give an example
if you knew that you had stage four lung
cancer
and let's say you hadn't prepared a will
or decided who your kid's god parents
were right um if you knew that you could
potentially take your last breath
tomorrow
would you say screw it and have a party
today or or
would you get your affairs in order
that's an expression for a reason it's
it's a silly saying that's live like
there's no tomorrow and it's even
it's even dumber when you look at the
people who who use it to live
wrongly and i'll tell you right now
there may not be a tomorrow
you could die tonight none of us know
when it'll come it'll come like a thief
in the night
but that's the difference between
happiness and fulfillment
pleasure versus purpose and that's where
we have brokenness here in this country
whether it relates to riots whether it
relates to young crime drug
use is that we've conflated this idea of
happiness
of pleasure with fulfillment and purpose
and i'll tell you you may come straight
from the pit of hell it is not what is
meant for your life and as it relates to
youtube with us
um i've seen a lot of people on youtube
a lot of people in the political
movement live like there's no tomorrow a
lot of conservatives
and when we were targeted what we would
have felt
best would have been to throughout this
year and a half or even longer
reveal all of this private information
with total reckless abandon
to go all guns blazing and just go down
in a blaze of glory right it would have
been cathartic it would have it would
have felt
great but i guarantee you
i guarantee you that listen it would
have been more fun
talking back and forth with you for a
year and a half and and during
okay let me try and clear for this it
would have been more fun to just go to
you and say look we're getting banned on
social media how often he says look
we're getting banned oh please donate to
my gofundme that would have been a whole
lot more fun
if i thought there was no tomorrow than
the going back and forth
with people at youtube and google for a
year and a half during which time
that was misrepresented brow beaten
dismissed
these were not pleasant experiences for
me and there were times where i just
wanted to shout what was going on from
the rooftops like the rikala guy but
guess what there is a tomorrow
listen for better or worse um this is
and i would say
worse this is the biggest right leaning
channel ever on youtube
ever i only came from montreal you know
over his head but if i acted
irresponsibly if i acted on my feelings
it would make it that much harder for
the next guy trying to come up on
youtube to make some headway on this
platform
that's what i have to be concerned but
that's what everyone here has to be
concerned with and that's why it's been
a very long
year and a half a pride swallowing siege
that we will never fully tell you about
because there is
a tomorrow and guess what my legacy our
legacy here
is you and we can't abandon you
even if accidentally just because we
want to act on our feelings so don't
live like there's no tomorrow live like
your actions
will affect those you love the ones you
love most for the rest of time all right
love you guys
see you next week monday alex jones
subject for today
[Music]
we
we
just
[Music]
positions
[Music]
that's up it's doing
you